Let's do this, dude. I'm going to tell you something right now, San Diego,
you know how I feel about you? All right.
You know how I felt about you in the past years when I go to San Diego and I
play the loyal con LA Jolla comedy store,
it's always some holier than they'll like,
guys that get drunk that think that everything's offensive.
Even though it's filled with Republicans, it's still very weird.
San Diego. You know, when I played the house of blues,
I had to throw up people before I even got on stage because there were drunk
princesses in bros luck that I have a good time know that I still get
bags.
Okay.
Didn't like it added some dates on this. Follow the leader tour for,
uh, uh, for, uh,
San Diego put up one, sold out very quickly,
put up another one, sold out very.
Quickly, put up a third one.
Sold out. Not as quickly, but still even before the show started.
All good. Okay.
Now I was ready. I was ready, dude.
I was ready for some combat comedy. You know what I'm talking about?
And I don't like combat comedy.
A lot of people think that I do like combat comedy because I like to slam
people. But the truth is, dude, I don't like to slam people. You understand?
Sure. I'll open the door to, you know,
to Dennis for anybody large or small male, female don't care. I don't even care.
If you have disabilities, everyone gets equal slams. It doesn't matter.
If you all feel like a person, if you're going to, you know what I mean,
step into the octagon.
Now.
You're going to get a Denny's grand slam. If you,
so I'm ready for some comeback. You.
I don't like a lot of people think I do because I do it.
I take it to the streets at Twitter. I take it to the streets, you know,
on my left left factor. YouTube people are Heckerling heckling,
and you got the videos and I'm just talking. People think I like that.
I've weened it out over the time because I have Netflix specials in a comedy
central spec special. And people think that now that okay,
he's actually a legit comedian. He doesn't do all the only the clap backs,
but then I'm ready to take it to the streets at Twitter. But I did not want to,
I'm like one of those serious, I'm like one of those serial killers.
That's just like, I don't want to do it. You know, but I have to. No,
not even that like a Hitman. I don't want to do that,
but I need to feed my family. The feeding,
the family in this case is me showing people what's up.
That's so most important thing for me showing people what's up.
People say Chris, but don't be mean, but I say, but look, you need to know,
right. They said, but Chris don't take them to the streets at Twitter.
But I say, but he needs to know, but he didn't tag you. That's right.
Because I searched my name, but isn't that petty? I don't think so.
I think more of it is that he needs to know.
You understand if this is the internet and this is what the internet is,
then that needs to know what this internet is.
So that's it. Okay.
Somebody did it just right now. It's somebody tweeted something.
I just lamps, whatever it doesn't matter, dude.
My point is I was all ready for some combat comedy.
First show went off without a hitch. Second show went off without a hitch.
Third show went out. Now I throw a guy out,
but it was still not so bad for San Diego. It was fine. Did I throw out a guy?
Yes. Did I do it very quickly? Yes.
Did I do it in the part of my act where the only place I could do it? Yes.
Did the security escort him out? Yes.
Did he throw down a trash can in the lobby when he was escorted out? Yes.
Did he try and fight the security? Yes. Did they call the cops? Yes.
Did the cops come? Yes. Did they put him in handcuffs? Yes.
Did his girl try and kick the cops and then the cop slammed the girl to the
ground.
There you go. Yes. But still wants it to three shots in that bag.
So San Diego I've come around, dude.
Hmm.
Dude. I've come around, man. I had a good show. I had good three shows.
Now one guy that was surely stockier than he is tall and had a backwards,
Hurley hat surely and had a flannel buttoned up all the way to his neck,
Shirley and a girl with a CR with a body that does it. Isn't that good,
but isn't pretty passable for not working out. Shirley
was trying to ruin it,
but did the cops come and do a [inaudible] and put her on the ground and cuff
him up and put them in the drunk tech? Yes.
So San Diego I've come around, dude,
still to those people, but also San Diego I've come around.
I'm a morning. DJ. My babies.
I got a keyboard dude and I use it,
But that's it dude. So I'm at a good time. So San Diego.
I stayed at the Pendry hotel. And usually when I go into.
Uh, uh, a town, you know,
I in my head, I'm like, don't talk to me when I check in.
I don't want people saying. I don't want to, I, you know,
I don't like to be bothered with fans. I like them when they like me from afar,
but I don't like them. Number one, staring, if you look at me,
if you see what's the 50 cent sign, what's the 50 cent line,
CBR public dance therapy, man, whatever the it is. I dunno, whatever the it is.
I used to think that was weird, but now I get it.
Cause I'm as famous as 50 cent. So, so I see it.
I don't like to be doing the, but then when they S when was I saying, so
what was I saying? Uh, then, uh, Oh yeah. So,
but secretly I'm ready for it. Wasn't happening so much in San Diego.
I was like, is it? Cause I'm close to LA. And it wasn't because I was to LA.
It was because I wasn't even close to the most feminist person staying at the
hotel because it was the San Diego international film festival.
Now why do they call it the San Diego international film festival when it's 30
minutes away from LA, it doesn't need to say it's international,
even though it is international because they accept movies from all over the
place. I get it. But don't say it to try and make your sound better.
It doesn't matter. Is it very San Diego.
Gas.
But I was in the elevator and I saw the guy from, um,
Chernobyl. And I told my dad, I saw the, the guy for the lead from Chernobyl.
And he said, Oh, which one from Shinola? And I said, the lead. And he said,
well, which one is that? And I said, did you see it? And he said, yes.
So I said, well then the guy who is in it the most,
and then he said, Oh, and they said the guy's name.
And I didn't know what his name was. And my mom said, yeah.
And that whole conversation is interesting because it didn't
need to happen. Didn't stand my dad's the King of that, dude.
Yeah. Yeah. I saw the lead at Chernobyl and the, in an elevator. Oh,
which one's the lead? Well, you're a director and a producer in Hollywood.
So you surely know what a lead is, right? Well, yeah, but which one was it?
Well, did you see the show while I only saw the first three episodes. Oh, okay.
So the guy that was in those episodes the most,
then he said the guy's name, Jared Harris. And then I said, yes,
conversation over. Did we need to have it? No.
To get their together. But I do that too. Like father, like son,
the Apple doesn't fall far from the tree and it's not my fault.
Did his dad Vincent do it? Probably. I don't know,
but did, my grandpa, everyone called him his name. We called him grandpa.
Bam. Everyone called him. Bam. Because when he was a kid,
he was skinny as a bamboo stick, but he wasn't skinny when he was older.
So it was always confusing for me as a kid, my grandpa bam.
Anyway, um,
it's so
New York in the fifth thirties to be named Vincent,
but also go by bam. You know what I mean?
Like that old, uh,
uh, like the old like,
Hey bam. Yeah. Don't call me that.
Good. Hey bam. Yeah. And don't call me that. My name is Vincent. Nah,
you're skinny. Like a bamboo stick. Yeah,
but I don't want to be called bam ad doesn't matter. And it stuck
and it kept sticking and then just a montage of him growing up. Hey,
getting in fights and. Hey Dylan. And that's where I was.
That's where I was everyone too.
Kind of grew on me.
Then just him dealing drugs.
[Inaudible].
Um, so anyway, bam, my grandpa bam. So whatever the dude.
So anyway, uh, w w what I'm trying to say is, uh, uh,
San Diego I've come around, but, uh,
it's all good. And I was in Riverside too. Everyone always talks about, look,
when you say you're going to Riverside,
everyone always talks about her Riverside. They're like, Oh man,
you stay in the night. I hope not, dude.
It ripped. I did Riverside. I love performing in Riverside,
stayed the night in Riverside. Okay.
I stayed the night in Riverside, man. That's an hour and a half away.
I stayed the night, dude, do you understand me?
And I stayed in a hotel that was not good.
Fine. Now did,
by the way, there was some kind of parade in Riverside or something.
And it really me off. I woke up, it woke me up in the morning. I heard people.
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh
[inaudible]. And then I was.
I was like, I was like, am I dreaming this?
And then they just heard coming closer and closer. And then I just kept.
Hearing boom blue. And I was like, Oh.
Riverside, dude. It does suck, man.
But then I woke up and there was just so many,
I don't know what parade was going on on Saturday or Friday or what was it?
I guess it was Friday morning.
Who the has a parade on Friday morning,
Riverside. That was the best they could get. They were like,
can we get a Saturday or Sunday parade? And they were like, nah, it's Riverside,
man. Parades. They're moving. They get to San Diego and LA by,
by Saturday and Sunday. All right, let's just do it Friday.
And then, so they did their parade. I don't even know if there was a parade.
I just kept waken up. By the time I woke up, woke up, it was, it was done.
It wasn't really a PR definitely wasn't a parade though.
It was like just people marching around and.
But then I went outside and I got some coffee. That was good.
And I got a breakfast sandwich. That was good.
And it was a coffee bean and tea leaf right there.
It was a cute little town dude. I feel like Riverside is on the come up, man.
But at a good time in Riverside, the crowds are always good in Riverside.
Uh, I don't know why people are always like, yeah,
but that's because they don't have anything to do, bro.
They look like they're doing just fine.
Also some places that don't have anything to do their
crowds suck like in North Battleford
when I was in Canada and every piece of artwork was a
tan and Aqua Marine Eagle.